travelling in a bus through southern
afghanistan
these passengers were approaching a
checkpoint around midnight
when their bus drove over a mine their
journey now one of recovery in merwice
regional hospital
the latest casualties in an increasingly
insecure country
when our vehicle approached the
checkpoint the bomb exploded many people
were killed and
injured i saw people's hands and feet
had fallen to the ground
they were not themselves two more bomb
blasts followed one in par one that
killed two passengers
another targeted soldiers in western
pharaoh province killing several
in afghanistan this was a bloody weekend
on monday a hillside in western kabul
was scored with dozens of fresh graves
teenage girls were targeted as they left
school on saturday with three separate
bombs
it was the deadliest attack in more than
a year and targeted members of the
hazara ethnic group
a sheer minority according to the new
york times in the weeks starting april
30th
140 government forces and over 40
civilians were killed across
afghanistan the highest death toll in a
single week
since october the afghan government said
the taliban were responsible
the taliban blamed isil and afghan
intelligence services
these are not our goals killing innocent
people even these are against our goals
because our goal is protection of for
the common people
protection of places national projects
that we have announced the rise in
casualties has coincided with the final
pull-out of foreign troops
may 1 was the former deadline for the
withdrawal of american troops from
afghanistan
u.s president joe biden pushed that back
to september 11th
their nato allies will leave then also
eu foreign ministers met on monday the
withdrawal from afghanistan at the
forefront of discussions
after the terrible attacks in the recent
days it's all the more important for the
eu to make very clear that afghanistan
and the afghan government can continue
to count on europe's support
we'll do everything we can to ensure the
ongoing peace negotiations reach a
conclusion
a key goal in u.s and nato negotiations
with afghan and taliban representatives
has always been a reduction in violence
and after an horrific weekend
some progress the taliban announced a
rare three-day ceasefire for the muslim
eid holidays
it will be only the third break in
fighting in nearly three years
a brief reprieve for those caught in the
middle charlotte ballas
al jazeera well may has been the
deadliest month in afghanistan this year
it coincides with the ongoing withdrawal
of u.s and nato troops
ending a 20-year presence in the country
the most recent attack on a girls school
on saturday in kabul killed more than 50
people most of them students
at least 160 pro-government forces and
over 65 civilians have been killed in
separate incidents
bringing the total death toll to over
220 people
in just the last 10 days the united
states under the trump administration
agreed to withdraw
all its troops by may 1st but washington
missed that deadline the pull-out began
this month
and is expected to end by september the
11th as per the new deadline set by
president biden
bahia is a lecturer of peace and
conflict mediation at cardinal
university he joins us now
live via skype from kabul good to have
you with us this time
yesterday i was talking to the taliban's
media spokesperson who was responding to
the government's assertion
uh that the taliban was responsible for
that blast
at the school on saturday it wasn't us
he said
how can you be so sure i asked him is
the taliban united
in its aims and objectives
uh first off escalation violence is a
very natural
part of peace processes because
different parties use it for leverage
again the taliban denying responsibility
serves them very well
because they tend to avoid international
scrutiny
while achieving military goals
the more important and difficult
question to ask is
if truly the taliban are not behind
these attacks then
there is a group here that has the
capacity and the sophistication to carry
such uh complicated attacks
however there is also a discord or the
better term to be used is tension
amongst the taliban leadership as well
the taliban leadership
is divided into moderates um that
include mullah brother and
malaya and on the other end they're
hardliners like
zada who heads the taliban movement
and this escalation and violence sort of
creates a polarity
amongst them which makes it very
difficult to reconcile visions at the
end of the day
the problem with this escalation in
violence of course
is that that the taliban is supposed to
be preparing to to
integrate its fighters into the system
how does it do that
uh when people are so
against it because of what it's doing to
ordinary people in afghanistan
again the second level of polarity
exists among the
foreign society as well iran people
don't even understand
what the utility of peace is anymore
with everything that is happening
um we need to also understand that there
is um
peace is not an event it's a process
right reconciliation has to start with
building mindsets towards peace uh
according to the
united states institute of peace
mohammed mansoor back the deceased
taliban leader back in 2015-16
had already started conducting workshops
for taliban fighters
to get them soften them up to the
prospects of peace
now with the escalation and violence
what i fear is
that if the taliban fighters are
smelling military victory
um they will not give into any
settlement because at the end of the day
if a total war and total victory can be
achieved
why settle why compromise that would be
something that's going in the heads of
the
fighters of the taliban that's something
that the taliban leadership
seriously need to address because these
fighters will not
change within a day will not join the
political system will not reintegrate
um there has to be a gradual reduction
in violence
for us to achieve that goal really good
to talk to you so many thanks indeed to
obey dollar by here there
in kabul